POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
>> >> Shannon: OKAY COME ARE
WE READY TO REOPEN THE COUNTRY?
LET’SLET’S TALK WITH LOUISIANA
CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL JOHNSON AND
OPENING UP AMERICA AGAIN
CONGRESSIONAL GROUP.
HE IS A REPUBLICAN AND IT’S GOOD
TO HAVE YOU BACK WITH US,
CONGRESSMAN.
>> HEY, SHANNON, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
>> Shannon: OKAY, LET’S TALK
ABOUT HOW SOME OF THIS WILL GO
DOWN.
STENY HOYER A TOP DEMOCRAT
EXCUSE ME SECOND DEMOCRAT IN THE
HOUSE IS THIS "THE
ADMINISTRATION FAILED TO
COMPREHENSIVE AND EFFECTIVE
REGIME TO DIVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
LEAD THIS CRISIS NOW SAYING
STATES MUST COME UP WITH THEIR
OWN WAY OF PRODUCING TENS OF
MILLIONS OF TEST REQUIRED THAT
THE SHOCKING EVOCATION OF THE
PRESIDENT’S DUTY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE."
SO CONGRESSMAN WHAT IS YOUR
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
AVAILABILITY OF TEST AND WHETHER
SAFE, THE FEDS, HOW IS THIS
WORKING OR NOT WORKING?
>> WELL, WHAT IS SHOCKING MY
FIRST REACTION IS WHAT IS
SHOCKING IS THAT DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS WANT TO POLITICIZE THIS
WHEN THIS IS NO TIME FOR
POLITICS.
WE ALL NEED TO BE PULLING
TOGETHER.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING THAT WITH
THESE TASK FORCES, COMMUNICATING
DIRECTLY WITH THE GOVERNORS.
AS HE TOLD US ON A CONFERENCE
CALL YESTERDAY MORNING, ALMOST
ALL OF THE GOVERNORS ARE
COOPERATING WITH HIM VERY WELL
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE HAVE TO SOLVE
THIS CRISIS.
TESTING IS NOT THE END-ALL,
BE-ALL AS YOUR OPENING SEGMENT
JUST ILLUSTRATED.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN.
THIS IS A HISTORIC,
UNPRECEDENTED RAMP-UP AND WHAT
ALL OF THE SUPPLIES THAT ARE
NEEDED TO.
AND AS YOU JUST SAID, 17 MILLION
MORE SWAB TEST ADDED TO THE
TESTS THAT ARE ALREADY OUT THERE
IN THE NEXT 35 TO 40 DAYS.
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
DOING EVERYTHING IT POSSIBLY
CAN.
TO THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
LOOK AT THE GOVERNORS AND THE
STATE UNDER OUR SYSTEM OF
FEDERALISM TO STEP UP INTO
HELPING TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS
THEY WILL HAVE THE EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID AND YOU
HEARD HIM SAY HIT HIMSELF, IF
THEY DON’T HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
WE WILL HELP THEM GIVE IT.
THAT IS ALL YOU CAN ASK OF
WASHINGTON.
>> Shannon: WELL, YOU KNOW HIS
CREDITS TO MY CRITICS SAY HE HAD
THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS ABOUT OPENING AND CLOS
MANY PEOPLE SEEMED REASONABLE.
THERE IS CRITERIA, DATA DRIVEN
AND IT DOES NOW GIVE AUTHORITY
TO GOVERNORS TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS FOR THEIR STATE.
BUT INCLUDING THE MAN WHO WANTS
TO UNSEAT HIM AND TAKE HIS JOB
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
SAID "I DON’T CALL THIS A PLAN.
I THINK WHAT HE DONE HE PUNTED
AND HE DECIDED HE’S NOT NOT AN
ALLEY DOESN’T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
MAKE THE CALL FOR THE COUNTRY."
SO THE TWO AUTHORITARIANS NOW
PUNTING BUT WHAT IS A FAIR
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE?
>> I THINK JOE BIDEN WOULD
CRITICIZE PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT
WHATEVER HE DID COME IT WOULD BE
WRONG.
HIS ARMCHAIR QUARTERBACK AND HE
HAS A LUXURY OF DOING THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE OTHER
SIDE HAS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
LEADING THIS NATION.
MOST AMERICANS APPRECIATE WHAT
IS DONE PLEADING WITH AUTHORITY
AND CONVICTION IN BEING
ACCEPTABLE TO EVERYONE.
HE’S OUT THERE EVERY SINGLE DAY
COMPLETELY TRANSPARENT AND WHAT
HE’S DOING.
I THINK IT WAS REALISTIC AND
RIGHT FOR HIM TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS HAS TO BE A
STATE-BY-STATE DECISION.
THERE’S NOT A ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL
HERE.
EVEN WITHIN STATES LIKE MY STATE
OF LOUISIANA, WE HAVE BEEN HIT
HARD BY THIS PANDEMIC, BUT WHAT
MAY BE NECESSARY IN NEW ORLEANS
FOR REOPENING PROTOCOL, IT MAY
NOT BE THE SAME WHERE I LIVE IN
NORTHWEST LOUISIANA.
SO THERE HAS TO BE THAT DECISION
MADE BY THOSE ON THE GROUND AT
THE LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL.
THEY ARE THE ONLY ONES THAT CAN
ACCURATELY ASSESS THAT DATA.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT IS REALISTIC AND THAT IS
WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN.
>> Shannon: YOU HAVE HAD A
REALLY ROUGH TIME OF IT DOWN IN
NEW ORLEANS AREA.
LOUISIANA HAS HAD REAL STRAIN ON
YOUR MEDICAL RESOURCES DOWN
THERE.
AND THE GOOD PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING QUITE A BIT.
WITH UPCOMING TORNADOES TO THE
SOUTH AND ALL KINDS OF THINGS
YOU GUYS HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH.
IN THE MEANTIME, PEW RESEARCH IS
LOOKING INTO PEOPLE’S ATTITUDES
AND HAD THESE FEELINGS OF
REOPENING.
WHEN THEY WERE ASKED ABOUT
CONCERNS OF RESTRICTIONS ON
PUBLIC ACTIVITY, CONCERNS THEY
WOULD BE LIFTED TOO QUICKLY 66%
NOT QUICKLY ENOUGH, 32%, WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS A LITTLE BIT
LAST NIGHT BUT HOW DO YOU REGAIN
THE CONFIDENCE OF THE AMERICA
AMERICAN CONSUMER WHETHER THEY
FEEL GOOD ABOUT SENDING THEIR
KIDS BACK OUT OR GOING TO A
RESTAURANT WHEN THOSE
APPROPRIATE TIMES COME
STATE-BY-STATE?
HOW DO YOU REASSURE AMERICANS
THEY WILL BE SAFE IN IN THE WAY
THAT WE NEED THEM TO?
>> THIS WILL BE A REAL TEST FOR
INSTITUTION.
AND WE NEED SOUND LEADERSHIP
FROM A STEADY HANDS AT THE WHEEL
AT THE LOCAL, STATE AND OF
COURSE, THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PUT OUT THE
GUIDELINES, THESE THREE PHASE
PROTOCOL AND STEPS TO GET BACK
TO SUBSTANCE OF NORMALCY.
WE ARE ALL EAGER TO DO THAT.
WE UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TO BECAUSE
SHANNON, YOU KNOW AND WE HAVE
ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS IDEA
WE HAD A POINT OF DIMINISHING
RETURNS ON THIS VERY SOON.
PUBLIC HEALTH TO BE THE DRIVING
FORCE BEHIND THIS AND IT SHOULD
BE, YOU HAVE TO REALISTICALLY
LOOK AT THIS.
IF YOU KEEP THINGS CLOSE DOWN
TOO LONG, THAT HAS A TERRIBLE,
LONG TERM EFFECT ON PUBLIC
HEALTH.
IT LEADS TO MORE PROPERTY, AND
IT LEADS TO RECORD LEVELS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT THAT COULD BE
SUSTAINED.
THOSE ARE ALL THE FACTORS THAT
HAVE TO BE CONSIDERED HERE.
WE WANT TO OPEN THE ECONOMIES
AND PEER THAT IS WHAT’S GOING TO
MAKE PEOPLE FEEL CONFIDENT AGAIN
WHEN THEY SEE THINGS GETTING
BACK TO NORMAL.
WHAT IS NORMAL AGAIN.
THAT WILL SPAWN MORE ACTIVITY
AND GET PEOPLE DIGNITY AND THEIR
WORK TO GO BACK TO WORK.
WHEN WE CAN GET THE KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL AND LARGE VENUES REOPEN
AND PEOPLE BACK IN CHURCH, I
THINK THEY WILL FEEL ACE GROWING
SENSE OF CONFIDENCE ABOUT WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
WE HAVE TO DO THAT SOONER THAN
LATER AND I THINK EVERYBODY
RECOGNIZES THAT.
>> Shannon: WE ARE PULLING FOR
YOU FOLKS IN LOUISIANA AND THE
HOUSE AS YOU PUT TOGETHER A